so I'm going to be talking about how we
came to study genes for aging or to ask
whether there were genes for aging those
genes that affect aging and we started
this work in the early 1990s and at that
time people didn't think that aging was
subject to any kind of control by the
genes they thought you just wear out
like an old car wears out and there are
several reasons that I thought maybe
this would be wrong this idea was
simplistic one is that if you just look
around in biology nothing just happens
it seems like everything seems to be
regulated everything seems to be subject
to control by the genes and when you
look at different species of animals you
see that they can have really different
lifespans and so the reason they have
different license obviously is because
they have different genes so that tells
you right off the bat that genes have a
lot to do with you know the lifespan of
an animal so I have been working in the
field of developmental biology and
during the time during that 1980s and
early 1990s it had become really clear
that basic fundamental mechanisms of
life are conserved evolutionarily so
this I lived through this realization in
the field of developmental biology when
genes that pattern the body of worms
which is what we worked on were the same
as genes that patterned the body of
fruit flies in mice which was amazing
because these animals look so different
but there was a lot of commonality there
and the same thing was happening in
other fields like the cell cycle is
driven by the same kinds of genes and
different kinds of animals so it seemed
to me that something so fundamental is
aging you know which seems to be
evolvable in other words there are lots
of there different animals but have very
different lifespans so evolution can
definitely change the rate of Aging so
anyway it seemed to me that there might
be genes that control aging and so to
find those genes you know if it animal
has them you could just you know treat
an animal with something that causes
mutations and look for long-lived
mutants so we didn't study this in in
humans instead we study it in our little
worms C elegans which is really nice for
this kind of study
cuz it's small and simple and it has a
very rapid life span of just a few weeks
and actually at the time we started our
experiments it was already known that
there was a gene that affected the
lifespan of C elegans and if you change
this gene the animals could live about
50% longer than normal but there was a
lot of mystery surrounding this gene it
this because these mutants for one thing
were not very fertile and so
evolutionary biologists thought that it
was possible that the reason that they
live long was that they didn't have to
channel all their resources into
reproduction so they would have more to
live longer but to me it seemed like
maybe it wasn't such a simple trade-off
maybe there really were genes that
control aging and I should say one more
thing which is I was really fascinated
by several things that have been known
for a long time one was progeria there
were human mutants that age much more
quickly than normal so that was really
interesting to me and the other thing
was that there was a phenomenon called
the hayflick limit where when you put
cells in culture they would just divide
several times or a few number of times
and then they would stop dividing and it
had been reported that if you took the
cells from a young person or animal they
divided more times than if you took them
from an old individual and so there was
some kind of intrinsic clock for aging
so as such a fascinating field and it
was discarded by molecular biologists
they just thought there was nothing to
study and anyway so we thought we'd give
it a try so I then decided okay I'm
going to look for genes that affect
aging we already had a lab working on C
elegans they were studying development
but my lab members had no interest in
aging they thought it was a real kind of
a what's the word a swamp is that the
word anyway not very interesting and
most people had that idea because it was
nothing to study and among molecular
biologists the field of aging had a kind
of bad reputation so I couldn't get
anyone to work on the project but the
idea was to look for long-lived mutants
and so I kept trying and trying and
there these students called rotation
students who come in to UCSF where I
work UCSF and before they join a lab to
get their PhD they spend some time in
each of three labs so I tried to
interest these students and they didn't
weren't interested but then one student
named Rahman tapped young finally
thought it was a great idea
yeah and he decided to look for
long-lived mutants so amazingly enough
he set out to look for lonely mutants
and he found he's found one he found
that mutations that reduce the activity
of a gene called Daffy to double the
worms lifespan here you see him in black
you see the lifespan of a normal worm so
by the end of 30 days a month or so all
the worms are dead but you see in red
the daf-2 mutant lives twice as long as
normal even more than twice as long and
the thing that was the most cool about
this was that the worms were they didn't
just go into the nursing home and hang
on they were actually aging more slowly
than normal and I have a movie here to
show you this so what this shows you
first is a normal worm just to orient
you so this is a young C elegans adult
when it's about graduate student age
it's three days in worm time and this is
the long live mutant when it's young and
the reason I'm showing you this is so
that you can see that the mutant looks
healthy and active looks great and in
fact these mutants can be completely
fertile so there was no reproductive
trade-off involved here okay so here is
a here's a normal worm when it's old you
see its head is moving here but
otherwise it looks like it's about to
die and it is about to die and now the
next you're going to see the long-lived
mutants the exact same age and what
you'll see is that the mutant oh these
are some more a dead worm here and
another word that's in the nursing home
so now what you're going to see is that
at the same time the long-lived mutant
looks much younger than this and I
actually tell people about this and they
end up thinking oh it's like being 90
but looking really good when you're 90
like a nine year old who's healthy but
it isn't and here's a little analogy
it's like this suppose you're single and
maybe in your 40s and you're dating and
you find someone that you really like
and you go on a couple dates and then
you go with them to a restaurant and
you're sitting there with them and then
you ask well how old are you and they
say I'm 80 you go oh my god because they
look 40 and that's what it's like it's
like it takes two days to age as much as
you normally age in one day so it's just
something that the reason I keep
emphasizing this is that people don't
realize I mean this is not something in
our experience we'd never thought this
kind of thing could happen but it did we
just change one gene and we dub
the lifespan so I told you that was
really hard to find anyone to work on
this project or Ramon the grant the
rotation student who dis made this
discovery didn't join our lab he went to
another lab and I still couldn't get
anyone to work on the project but there
were all these experiments that we
wanted to do with daf-2 mutant so he
kept asking rotation students if they'd
like to work on it and they all did they
like to work on it so one after another
they would come to the lab and they
would do some more experiments on the
daf-2 mutants and finally we wrote a
paper for nature published the paper and
except for me every single person on the
paper was a rotation student and the
amazing thing is not one of those
rotation students joined the lab they
all went to other labs and it was really
a long time before anyone decided that
aging was a sure enough bet for a PhD
thesis that they would actually come to
the lab and work on it so what is this
gene what is this deaf - gene well the
Garry rough can slab cloned the gene and
they found that daf-2 encodes a hormone
receptor so that means hormones control
aging and not only that it's similar to
receptors that we knew about number one
this a human receptor for insulin which
is a hormone that controls nutrient
uptake and also it was similar to a
hormone called igf-1 which controls
growth and these hormones are similar to
one another that is it was similar to
the receptor for these four months okay
so so what our findings had showed was
that this um this the worms version of
this same receptor had a third function
it also controlled aging and we now know
that what happens is that when you when
you slightly damaged the DEF to gene
it's the animal sees it as a signal for
danger so it rolls out a protective
stress response and that's what makes it
live longer but anyway the big question
then of course was is this just a worm
thing or is this also the case for
higher organisms and I'll just say
really quickly that inhibiting this gene
can extend the lifespan of flies or mice
and there's a study of Ashkenazi Jews
carried out by NIR Barzilai and he
showed that centenarians are more likely
to have reduced function of the igf-1
receptor gene then our Ashkenazi Jews
who died earlier so at least in this
population this mutations in the same
gene have
been linked to exceptional longevity and
we also found a gene called f-16 is
needed for the long lifespan and humans
have this gene it's called Fox oh and it
turns out that Fox oh variants are
associated with exceptional longevity in
populations all around the world these
little stars all represent a population
showing that variance in this in this
longevity gene are present in people who
live to be alone to live a long time
okay so I think the bottom line here is
that you know we started because we had
an idea I had an idea that aging would
be regulated we were really really lucky
to find the daf-2 gene in fact my
colleagues had said to me one of them
said you know I knew people who started
to work on Aging and they just fell off
the edge of the earth as if the earth
was flat they just fell off the edge of
the earth but in this case we didn't
fall off the edge of the earth we found
something really really interesting that
may be conserved in humans and actually
these mutants are resistant to lots of
diseases so there all sorts of potential
here for improving human health okay but
that's the story thank you
you